ash wednesday marks the beginning of
Lent a period of 40 days when Christians
fast and do penance and preparation for
Easter
in Berlin the Roman Catholic Cardinal in
the city's Lutheran bishop traditionally
observed the day together with Berlin
artists they do so in a very special
place
this is the church of maria regina
material mary queen of martyrs only a
short distance from a former prison
where the nazis executed thousands of
their political opponents between 1933
and 1945
I
the church is consecrated to the memory
of those men and women who followed
their consciences and the dictates of
their faith and paid with their lives
sisters from the nearby Carmelite
convent gather in the crypt several
times a day to pray these nuns have
dedicated their lives to commemorating
the victims of Nazi brutality
photos angus is kind of blast I wouldn't
say it's a burden living here it's a
challenge because I'm constantly
confronted with people who gave their
lives for human dignity for the
preciousness of life and were brutally
murdered the cause of Allah dat warden
but I also recognize more and more that
these people in the face of death and
the violence they suffered experienced
the infinite love of God gratitude and
goodness yeah fun I not wanna mess we
can leave a got us front and back i doin
good that touches me deeply maria regina
martyrium is a unique building
consecrated in 1963 it includes the work
of the most important German artists of
the time this is kind of kidding Zaphod
see and measure it's not a church that's
immediately accessible at the beginning
I felt resistance toward the
architecture to listen but if you walk
through this church that you can see an
architectural purpose a spiritual
purpose and integrating the stones
themselves seem to speak to it if you
stand for a moment before entering the
courtyard below and take it in you begin
to see the familiar images we know of
the concentration camps those long rows
of people standing for roll call that
dark legacy appears before your eyes
fragment open the courtyard of maria
regina mártira completely shut off from
the outside world by high walls of dark
bassil drock the only entrance is a
small door from the street it's
reminiscent of something archaic
darkness and light play on the
cobblestones
it can hold 10,000 people a place of
death and grief it reminds us of human
suffering in the world but also of the
promise of redemption Hereafter
it's just a short distance on foot to
the blitzen's a memorial center which is
dedicated to the victims who suffered in
this former prison from nineteen thirty
three to nineteen forty-five those
sentenced to death by german courts were
executed here not just Germans but
French Russian polish and Belgian
prisoners more than two and a half
thousand people
a guillotine was used at first later
there were hangings the prisoners strung
up on butcher hooks alongside each other
in the crypt of maria regina material an
inscription commemorates two of the many
men murdered in blitzen's a one of them
was hello james graph and Mozgov a
lawyer and expert in military law
together with his wife Freya he lived on
the family estate car saw in Silesia in
what became known as the Casal circle
when Marta gathered together Christians
trade unionists humanists and fellow
lawyers who shared his conviction that
Hitler would lose the war they worked on
plans for the democratic Germany that
would emerge after the Nazis were
defeated the Jesuit priest in
sociologist Alfred dev a passionate
defender of the catholic church's social
teachings joined the Casal circle in
1942 after the failed assassination
attempt against Hitler on July twentieth
nineteen forty four del Benton martica
were arrested although they had nothing
to do with it
I Fredette was transferred from Munich
to Berlin where fun Mozgov was already
being held through the prison chaplain
the Catholic priest in the Protestant
aristocrat were able to send messages to
each other they prayed together by means
of tapping signals
the Gestapo offered to release tell if
he agreed to leave the Jesuit Order he
refused when Marta was put on trial
accused of little more than his
Christian principles both he and del
poor sentenced to death he wrote to his
wife we shall be hanged because we have
shared ideas kadmo james Van martika was
executed on january 23rd 1945 alfred
dead a week later on februari the second
kissed San can be tightened Eden all
seeing a Christian can mean drawing
courage from the life of Jesus and
saying nothing will happen to me I can
speak the truth I can risk standing up
and speaking the truth it's Azad which
many Christians failed to do during the
dictatorship about egli but that is what
it's really all about I cannot watch
while my neighbor is butchered and
remain silence Tom mentioned you don't
win this hand during the Third Reich
there were a few people who are able to
do that remembering them gives us
courage before in the end they believed
that they had acted correctly james
olmos james Van Malka and Alfred dealt
died and the knowledge that they had
done the right thing or does a sticky
katana
pinkish Rida born in 1944 has been an
active member of the parish most of his
life he served as an altar boy got
married in this church and his son was
baptized here Sharita helps out where
he's needed in the sacristy or at the
convent there's always something to do
north nod 950 I moved to this
neighborhood 1959 with my parents and my
brother we were both altar boys then
this church was built when the
foundation stone was laid I was 16 and
my brother was 19 my Buddha 10 Anton
in the grunstein that I place in the
foundation stone the book the markers
admonish us it tells the story of those
who suffered persecution and death in
our times for the sake of justice
womanhood alive in Muslim physical
damage as humor occasion music Ahaggar
corn I came here as a young organist to
dunk a little kid I made the decision to
come here when the church was still
being built but it took several years to
hear by Mary I and you told me
constantly I think the foundation stone
was laid in 1960 and I applied for a
position here because I thought this
church would be very important for West
Berlin adored endure for respite in sign
but
construction took three years from 1962
1963 it was a period in which few
Germans gave much thought to those who
had resisted the Nazis but the church
gained recognition not just by the
parishioners but by other Berliners and
Christians all over Germany
on his second day at work account from
Gagne played the organ at the
consecration ceremony because Yeremiah
the church was consecrated on May the
5th 1963 it was a huge event Road cast
on national television star sapphire at
our boredness afrikaans event two famous
German architects unshaded and friedrich
ebert designed the ensemble church
courtyard and parish center above the
dark stone walls of the courtyard they
placed a gleaming white church that
appears to float these are bow is wooden
an active site as a your special funny
this church is an example of what we
call post-war modernism kitten bowl is
at the time this was a really
significant church structure and it
still is today mutter yards it's both
modern and timeless it's modern and it's
use of material concrete which we see
everywhere especially exposed concrete
and there is timeless in its use of very
clear consistent foams it's very cure
metric everything is at a right angle
which was counted as a trend when you
compare it with other church buildings
of that period the late 1950s and early
1960s the dominant style then was very
figurative the idea of a church
structure as a tent a ship a fortress
this church is contrary to that trend
the invaders it's desi hill
crossing the courtyard visitors to this
church approach a monumental wall that
gleams in the Sun on one of the dark
walls are Stations of the Cross created
by the German sculptor auto habit Hayek
we
you sense the figures rather than see
them in high x abstract sculptures above
beams cross wedged into each other
proceeding along the Stations of the
Cross the number of crosses increases
they call to mind the death of Jesus
Christ they also represent the many
crosses of those murdered by the Nazis
on the memorial plaque in the crypt we
read the names of other men who are
executed for following their conscience
and their faith
one of them was been hot lichtenberg the
Provost of Berlin Cathedral after the
November pogrom of 1938 which the Nazis
called castana he told his parishioners
to pray for persecuted Jews and for the
inmates of the prison camps he himself
was arrested and died on his way to
Dachau concentration camp Irish krosno
was murdered in 1934 on the orders of
Yusuf Gerber's as the leader of catholic
action in berlin klausner exhorted his
fellow Germans to uphold Christian
values that cost him his life
the names in the crypt of maria regina
material are meant to represent the many
victims of the Nazi dictatorship the
building erected to their memory has
always drawn people to it
there are marzocchi is the space is
impressive in its simplicity and
monumentality wanna mentality so many
visitors say that even today behind son
order them as you go up the stairs it's
not something you really expect even
though you've seen its dimensions from
outside upon also added humans your neck
in after ascending the stairs to the
church you first enter a simple
vestibule under the organ gallery
concrete is also the main component of
the interior sunlight filters into the
room through narrow slots
the side walls embrace the inner core of
the church like two giant slabs the core
itself is formed by the other two walls
and the ceiling this events is a feeling
of eerie weightlessness despite the
massive concrete does characteristics
and ease in bal vikas Mundi what's
characteristic about this building is
the way that the form is visible in the
concrete you can see the structure of
the wooden mold into which the concrete
was poured at the end of the 1950's and
in the 1960s that was considered very
aesthetic it shows incidentally that
this building does follow a specific
architectural style or trend brutalism
the term comes from the french vuitton
blue one bit which means raw concrete
and when you look at this room you see
its qualities it has a tactile structure
you constantly feel the urge to touch it
I mr. de vendôme unfasten one of the
most remarkable things about this
building is the indirect lighting
without windows light only falls between
the gaps in the corners of the room
this indirect lighting results in soft
ambient illumination that is evenly
distributed depending on the time of the
day individual elements glow with warm
colors in a kind of unearthly light
that's why STIs acacia else must eat
minus T's our perspective is there soon
from here you can really see what's
special about this church on the one
hand we have these side walls of exposed
concrete and then in the east on the
wall behind us is a picture of the
apocalypse by the artist key of Meister
month it's very characteristic of the
church and he attacked the one and a
half kilometres behind that wall and
behind this building i should say is the
pledge sins a memorial center my stamens
all the painting relates to that limdi
the spirit fun my starman as least build
my man semester but sook
groups of school children often visit
the church maria regina material houses
works of art by the most important
german artists of the period the
enormous wall painting by Georg my
stamina a devout Catholic from the
Rhineland is a moving tribute to those
who resisted Nazi rule and the fact that
there were Christians among them it's s
that's not new it before I say anything
just look what's your first impression
that's it ssl abstract and then later um
all cities there is this dark frame
around it the lighter colors are inside
piercing yellow and green and a bit of
red down below fadi none um I'm the
mansion Joe the dark colors on the edge
could symbolize grief guns 50 custody
the Duncan farm and those dark colors
you mentioned are very important to
consult out the artist intention was to
show light struggling with darkness
deceased canta humans
on the monumental wall behind the altar
Georg my steam on painted a biblical
scene from the book of Revelation The
Last Judgment into the dark crumbling
world on the edges of the painting a
light shines as if out of infinity the
Lamb of God appears this is the eschaton
the end of time amended ethnicities
finally this church opens up to a new
dimension accompt the light you see
there is the light of hope which the
people in the death cells receive bonus
this is even but it is truly a new
dimension equals a good bite and then in
great tectonic movements the gloom of
the church opens itself to this light I
think it's beautiful and easily see when
the slum the sad at the center of this
light you see the lamb looking at gdf
and the eye of God giveth Union did was
what Delp and Mulkey experienced in
their selves wrestling with death with
Moxon they suddenly had the feeling that
it made sense what they were suffering
they've been to the end dealt was able
to say we die so that others can have a
better life on ibuki finding and that's
what you can experience personally in
this church the process from death to
life that's why for me personally the
Good Friday and Easter celebrations here
are especially moving and enthralling
patent is
at six o'clock on Easter morning the
service begins in the courtyard in front
of the church but wishful oneself odd
father and creator of all living
creatures bless this fire that
illuminates the night light in us anew
the confidence that your actions are
able to transform the darkness of human
life into new light of abundant amok and
flammia known and flaming us the longing
for you the eternal life and light we
ask this through Christ our brother and
Lord
maria regina Marty Rome is not just a
memorial it is a place of worship a
Catholic Church where Protestants also
come to pray
above the entrance to the church is a
sculpture by the artist for its konak
the apocalyptic woman a sign of victory
a symbol of hope it shows an image from
the book of Revelation the Dragon lies
in wait ready to devour the child to
whom the woman is about to give birth
but she and the child are saved
good triumphs over evil that is the
message of this church each day the
Carmelite Sisters gather in the crypt to
pray for peace
Fritz kunuk the artist who created the
apocalyptic woman also made this pietà
the mother of god holds her crucified
son in her arms maria regina materon
mary queen of martyrs maria big in zoo
infirmary holds her son and this
symbolizes God's tender support or in
the words of the prophet Isaiah God has
engraved us on the palms of his hands
what does instability that is what this
church proclaims here you see for names
representing all those who were murdered
Hitler wanted to erase all memory of the
helmet James von Moltke alpha delt
Provost lichtenberg who was supposed to
be buried here but is in fact buried in
st. Hedwig's Cathedral and dr. Eric
Klausner the only grave that is actually
filled he really is buried here yet and
the pietà says as it were your names are
not forgotten yes do Mary also
represents the church and that is the
aspect of mission the church reminds
itself that these names must never be
forgotten Dusty's anam an August
forgetting bed
you